Speaker 1: We are increasingly seeing reporting
that the reason for all of this trouble at Mar
a Lago is a traitor or a mole inside Donald
Trump's circle. Now, there's a couple different
elements to this. One is, is there a high
level traitor like Mark Meadows? Mark Meadows
name is one that is frequently mentioned. But then
there's also a more nitty gritty question of like,
is there just someone at Mar a Lago that has
been involved in feeding information to the feds
about where things are being kept in Donald
Trump's home or whatever the case may be?
Increasingly, seeing more and more reporting
on this businessinsider quote, quoting Axios.
Trump allies think there is a traitor in
Mar a Lago who informed on him to the FBI.
Allies of Trump believe an aide or aides to Trump
may have flipped and provided evidence to the FBI
about what he was keeping in his Mar
a Lago resort in Florida, per Axios.
When we look at the Axios report, one
big thing Trumpworld suspects a flipper.
Trumpworld is abuzz with speculation about
which close aides or aide has flipped and
provided additional sensitive information to
the FBI about what Trump was keeping their.
Trump's orbit is always an environment rife with
mistrust and paranoia, and it is intensified
in a detail that seems to novelistic to be true.
A focal point of the search was the Mar a Lago
basement. Christina Bobb, a lawyer for Trump, told
The Washington Post his lawyers held discussions
with the Justice Department this spring. Bobb
said Trump's legal team search through two dozen,
2 to 3 dozen boxes in a basement storage area,
hunting for documents that could be considered
presidential records. Bob told The Post that
in June, Trump lawyers showed those boxes to
investigators and they already look through
it. She said the investigators didn't think
the storage unit was secured, so Trump officials
added a lock. FBI agents broke through the lock
during the search and then took a dozen boxes.
Newsweek, also exclusively reporting an informer,
told the FBI what documents Trump was hiding and
where the raid on Mar a Lago was based largely on
information from an FBI confidential human source
who was able to identify what classified documents
Trump was still hiding in the locations. The
officials who have direct knowledge of the FBI's
deliberations were granted anonymity, said the
raid of Trump's home was deliberately timed to
occur when Trump was away. FBI decision makers in
Washington, in Miami thought that denying Trump
a photo op or a platform from which to grandstand
or try to thwart the raid would lower its profile.
That failed. It prompted a furious response from
Republican leaders. This is completely plausible.
As with many of these things, we often because of
the documentation being not public, we often don't
understand. And because of the need to protect
informants, we often never learn everybody that is
in touch with law enforcement in advance of such
an action. But it would be completely reasonable
to think that something like this took place.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE believes it, and she's
on the case and she wants the traders found.
Speaker 3: I do not want him in there.
And they're so hell bent on it. Guess what? We
now know that there was an FBI informant at Mar
a Lago, an FBI informant working at Mar a Lago.
Speaker 1: By the way, she says she knows this
based on media reports, the very same media she
often decries as fake news that tells lies again.
It's just what's convenient for us
right now. Right now it's convenient
to believe those reports in the media.
Speaker 3: Is that and how many other
FBI informants are around President Trump on a
daily basis, working at his clubs, working at
Mar a Lago or maybe Bedminster or on Bedminster?
Speaker 1: I know that's completely an aside.
Bedminster. Bedminster, please. Marjorie.
Speaker 3: Staff. These are the things I
want to know. Because they're traitors. They
are traitors. And they're helping the deep
state and they're helping the people. These are
the enemies within. These are the real enemies.
And they're there to purposefully, purposely
create something against President Trump
that is not there. It's absolutely
not there. And everyone knows that.
Everyone knows it. And if these people.
Speaker 1: So traitor is the word that Marjorie
Taylor GREENE and quite frankly, many in MAGA
world are using. Will we ever learn who it was?
Probably not. But from a political standpoint,
at a bigger picture level. Mark Meadows has
never publicly accused Cassidy Hutchinson of lying
during her testimony to the January six committee.
And so merely speculatively, it seems to me quite
plausible that Meadows is somewhere involved in
providing information to someone not could be
FBI could be January 6th, maybe, I don't know.
But his silence, when many others have said
Cassidy is lying, is very notable. That's probably
separate from whatever so-called the traitor was
at Mar a Lago. Probably two different stories.